bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue à tous
avant de commencer de préliminaires on
va peut-être faire un petit essai sur le
son donc merci d'utiliser le chat pour
nous dire si vous vous entendez bien
réponse que vous nous entendez pas
impec merci
super pouvoir démarrer dédié à la
médiation
la médiation vu comme une alternative
efficace pour gérer les courses
c'est vivre une médiation
et puis vous avez un chat vous avez déjà
utilisé pour me dire qu'elles sont
fonctionnels vous pouvez également
l'utiliser pour poser vos questions
merci Valérie
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce webinaire dans cet espace qui
vous est dédié à vous prix
notre projet ce soir c'est de vous faire
comprendre à quel point vous faire
ressentir à quel point la médiation est
un outil puissant que vous n'allez pas
tarder à utiliser au quotidien
pourquoi la médiation parce-que en fait
entre ce que vous pensez ce que vous
préparez dans votre tête comme et
finalement que vous dites est tout au
bout la chaîne ce que la personne en
temps et bien il y a un véritable océan
dans lequel il est vraiment difficile de
ne pas se noyer dans l'incompréhension
qui mène au confit
pour pouvoir comprendre l'autre il est
absolument nécessaire de changer. Et ça
c'est le rôle du médiateur le but d'une
médiation c'est d'amener les parties à
résoudre un conflit en s'engageant sur
un accord te juge équitable
la médiation existe depuis très
longtemps rappelez-vous l'arbre à
palabre en Afrique oui vous allez me
dire c'est pas en Afrique ici c'est la
France
qu'est-ce que la médiation pour les
entreprises qu'est-ce que ça va nous
apporter votre histoire
pour les entreprises la médiation va
permettre de rétablir le dialogue de
communiquer aussi bien avec des salariés
les associés avec vos clients vos
fournisseurs le propriétaire des locaux
vous occupez
tout est possible et imaginable
je vous entends de la me dira je vais
lui envoyer mon pire client là celui qui
me casse les pieds qui comprend rien
associer un petit peu bouchée
là je crois que vous commencez à tendre
l'oreille et à mes côtés
alors comment est-ce qu on arrive en
médiation y a 4 façons d'arriver en
médiation
la première simple c'est vous
prévoyez dans vos contrat une clause de
médiation de façon automatique
vous avez également la possibilité
lorsque vous arrivez dans une situation
conflictuelle de proposer à la personne
avec laquelle vous êtes en conflit de
tenter une médiation avant toute
procédure
de quelle figure que j'aime aussi des
sens qu'on appelle et médiation
conventionnelle
dans beaucoup de cas le conflit vous
êtes déjà amené à être en procédure
c'est pas grave il n'est pas trop tard
vous avez toujours la possibilité même
si vous êtes en procédure de proposer à
l'autre de rentrer en médiation de cette
médiation et puis il existe un dernier
cas de plus en plus fréquemment parce
que la loi le permet
lui-même
fortement à vous diriger vers la
médiation et deux derniers cas que je
viens tout ce qu'on appelle les
médiation judiciaire
comment est-ce que ça fonctionne
concrètement
c'est extrêmement simple le médiateur va
organiser des réunions avec les
personnes qui sont en conflit
éventuellement le
médiateur également la possibilité de
rencontrer séparément les personnes
il est important de retenir c'est que le
médiateur n'est pas un expert encore
c'est une personne qui a une autre qui
est impartial et qui n'impose surtout
aucune solution
médiateur c'est un facilitateur c'est
quelqu'un qui va vous accompagner vous
aider il va c'est comment écouter la et
l'autre il va vous aider à vous écouter
grâce à lui le dialogue va pouvoir
reprendre et ça de façon
protéger puisque les réunions sont
totalement
financières
et les avocats
combien de temps dure une médiation
entre deux à 3 mois pas plus
est-ce qu'il est très pratique avec la
médiation également si vous êtes aussi
protégé par rapport à une éventuelle
procédure si vous avez l'obligation
parce que malheureusement la médiation
ne fonctionne pas d'aller ensuite en
procédure et bien la durée de la
médiation aura suspendu le délai la loi
prévoit habituellement pour agir en
justice
aucun risque
je vois sourire je vous vois un peu
dubitatif pour certains vous êtes en
train de me dire attends là elle vient
de nous parler d'un truc et rapide et
confidentiel ou on a quelqu'un qui vient
nous accompagner et on trouve des
accords nous arrange tous les deux il y
a forcément quelque part
l'accord du médiation ne dit la loi a
autorité de la chose jugée qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'un accord
de médiation à la même valeur d'un
jugement et donc on va pouvoir le faire
exécuter s'il y a besoin de façon forcer
qui n'arrive pas souvent mais dans ce
cas-là on va pouvoir le présenter au jus
on appelle ça l'homologation
s'il y a besoin
parce que
stop
là je crois qu'on a un vrai confit
mesdames ce que je vous propose c'est
vous s'asseoir on va essayer de traiter
ça
tranquillement prenez place
occasion
à lustrer la médiation
bonsoir madame
je vous ai entendu parler de tribunal
entre nous
juste c'est véritablement d'être
volontaire
c'est un processus volontaire
il fait des sites internet qui composent
les pages et donc j'ai été mandaté par
les jouets pour faire un site marchand
on a eu un cahier des charges que j'ai
respecté
d'accord je vous écoute madame
je vais pas payer quelqu'un qui me fait
un site marchant sur la fonction
et qui part ailleurs on lui dit un logo
n'est pas capable de me mettre le logo à
la bonne taille
avant 6h la justice et bien je ne vais
pas voilà donc il est hors de question
que je paye madame je suis à la tête
d'une société qui vend des jouets c'est
une société qui existe et donc je ne
peux pas continuer avec Madame dans ces
conditions donc je ne sais pas.
alors de ce que je comprends vous
représenter tous les deux des sociétés
vous êtes des professionnels votre
société Madame s'appelle
et vous avez été sollicité pour qu'on se
voit pour la société
cette situation
je ressens
en colère
d'accord
[Musique]
est-ce que là-dessus on peut continuer
jusqu'à du coup
vous êtes rencontrés comment et quel est
votre mode de fonctionnement madame
la construction du sida par contre tout
ce qui était graphisme c'est pas moi qui
est pour certaines fonctionnalités comme
je ne sais pas tout faire
vous avez des charges vous êtes d'accord
sur effectivement
l'ensemble de la commande mais vous avez
une partie pour
tout
donc là ce que je vous propose c'est
peut-être de continuer ce processus et
puis on va continuer à essayer de
comprendre toujours un peu plus les
éléments qui constituent votre conflit
avant d'essayer de t'imaginer des pistes
de résolution
alors ce que Xavier viens de vous donner
à voir c'est ce qu'on appelle l'écoute
active l'écoute active c'est quoi c'est
écouter sans interrompre vous l'avez
compris se concentrer uniquement sur son
interlocuteur ne surtout pas juger et
accepter les émotions les sentiments les
actes les pensées des personnes avec
lesquelles on échange et puis dans un
second temps reformuler demander
confirmation de ce qu'on a envie qu'on a
entendu c'est une écoute qui est
profondément bienveillante vous avez
entendu Xavier utiliser ce terme son
jugement qui nécessite une grande
disponibilité et une ouverture d'esprit
pour se faire des amis et utilise une
technique qui s'appelle la reformulation
se déroule en deux temps la première
reprendre les propos de l'autre
reprendre ses mots relais redire en
d'autres termes pour que la personne
avec laquelle on est en couple fille
puisse ensuite les entendre et pour ça
on s'assure Xavier c'est assurer auprès
de la personne qu'elle ressent t-il
reformuler que ces propos était bien
valider donc la reformulation se situe
en deux temps l'effet recherché de la
reformulation et bien c'est entendre de
la bouche d'un tiers ce qui n'était pas
entendre table auparavant
donc vous avez entendu ce que nous
expliquer madame de la société est-ce
que j'ai bien compris de ce que vous
avez une problématique de 13h puisque
vous avez
que vous devez payer vous avez pour
l'instant de ma commande
c'est ce que l'on dit Madame de ses
besoins de ses difficultés par rapport à
cette situation
me dire votre besoin la média était
comment on peut avancer
je fais 70 % de mon chiffre d'affaires
sur les fêtes de fin d'année je n'ai pas
la fonction paiement je vends comment je
paye mes collaborateurs comment c'est
tout de même
situation et puis
voilà
d'accord et là
je vais payer les charges mes
collaborateurs
pour moi donc je suis oui je suis au
ne
suffisent pas et donc c'est pour cela
que nous avons développé de plusieurs
années plusieurs années un site web et
que je l'ai fait refaire et perfect
15 collaborateurs
[Musique]
ne correspond à rien qui ne respecte pas
ma charte graphique donc autant vous
dire que je suis fort mécontente
également
Cheikh on m'a donné un fichier avec des
codes sources je n'ai fait que prendre
ce fichier s'il est pas pour
rien
[Musique]
réinitialiser
danseuse dans cette discussion ce que
j'entends en fait c'est quand même une
grosse angoisse par rapport à cette
situation
tout conflit est l'expression
tragique d'un besoin insatisfait
c'est ce que nous dit Marshall Rosenberg
à nos aspirateurs à nous les médiateurs
la plante comme l'être humain a des
besoins primaires
dormir se nourrir
mais l'être humain en plus des besoins
secondaires
à travers la médiation le médiateur va
pouvoir mettre en lumière en s'attachant
sur les besoins qu'une personne par
exemple un besoin de reconnaissance
pourquoi est-ce que il est important de
s'attarder sur ses besoins parce que
répondre à une demande
sans satisfaire les véritables besoin
d'une personne ça ne permet pas de
résoudre les causes du conflit ça permet
au mieux de les camoufler
au contraire rechercher les besoins et
les intérêts de chacune des parties qui
sont en conflit va permettre ensuite de
combler ses besoins
si on comble vos besoins après vous êtes
bien
c'est une des particularités de la
médiation à laquelle vous venez
d'assister
contrairement à la procédure judiciaire
la médiation réparé
l'idée est de passer des positions à la
recherche des besoins
alors
par rapport au besoin
première phase du discussion vous avez
indiqué que vous avez indiqué que
il y a ce problème de trésorerie qui est
un problème qui est vraiment pour vous
pouvez pas avancer vers une solution
le compromis
et puis vous avez indiqué que par contre
sur les problèmes techniques
sur la question
oui oui tout à fait
intervient plus rapidement possible et
que la société
puisse avoir
si je reçois du graphiste de la société
joie Piou Piou un fichier avec ce logo
je peux moi-même en interne assez
rapidement le remettre en place et tout
à fait
et vous dit pour le free-lance il faut
qu'on règle la question de ce que je ne
peux pas avancer madame qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire est-ce que
du coup déjà un engagement fort
[Musique]
parce que j'ai besoin de
payer mais
moi aussi
[Musique]
d'accord d'accord donc du coup je prends
un grand soulagement
en fonction
cette réunion d'accord
du coup il faudra formaliser 7 accords
de médiation
donc du coup déjà avancé
je m'appelle au changement du nom
allemand.
écouter merci de vous être prêtée à
l'exercice
est-ce que vous venez de voir c'est la
fin de recherche des solutions lors de
cette phase vous avez pu le constater
Xavier a repris individuellement chacun
des différents aspects du conflit afin
d'en dégager des point d'entente
possible il a encouragé le dialogue la
communication comme toujours et essayer
de trouver une coopération pour résoudre
le conflit il est intervenu fréquemment
pour reformuler toujours et encore et
pour résumer préciser les fait le média
il faut savoir dans ce cas
on peut également s'entretenir
avec des personnes
qui malgré les efforts on aboutit à une
impasse alors le médiateur peut toujours
réveillé la flamme en rappelant à
chacune des parties qui a accepté de
rentrer en médiation les raisons pour
lesquelles elle a fait ce choix
il n'y a pas de formule magique pour
arriver à un accord chacun doit
réellement mettre du sien
si un accord et trouver si les parties
sont satisfaite du résultat alors le
médiateur va résumé
l'accord qui a été trouvé et les
solutions qui vont avec la colle ensuite
être précisé par écrit vous avez entendu
Xavier l'indiquer à chacune des
personnes en conflit attention ce n'est
pas le travail du médiateur il doit
rester toujours notre impartial donc il
n'a pas le droit de rédiger cet accord
c'est généralement travail des avocats
c'est d'accord évidemment doit ensuite
signer et le médiateur habituellement
reprends contact quelques semaines après
la fin de la médiation avec chacune des
parties qui était en conflit pour
s'assurer que l'accord a bien été
exécuté
alors convaincu
je pense que la question suivante celle
qui doit vous brûler les c'est mais on
le trouve où le médiateur
le conseil que nous pouvons vous donner
c'est vous adresser à une vraie
organisation une association structurée
qui va permettre d'organiser le
processus de médiation de A à Z qui va
aussi éviter les erreurs au casting et
vous adresser un médiateur qui aura les
compétences pour vous aiguiller par
rapport à votre coffee spécifique c'est
toujours du cas par cas
méfiez-vous il existe de plus en plus de
cabinet de médiation sur Internet qui ne
sont pas tous de qualité bien au
contraire vous avez pu constater lors de
cette médiation la médiation et un
exercice périlleux un exercice qui
demande de véritables compétences et une
formation
il existe d'ailleurs à ce jour des
formations dont des diplômes
universitaires pour accéder aux
fonctions de médiateur
dans l'Essonne il existe une association
qui s'appelle Essonne médiation et
arbitrage dans cette association nous
sommes tous former et par ailleurs tous
les adhérents tous les médiateurs de
l'association connaissent sur le bout
des doigts le droit puisque nous avons
comme particularités le reste de notre
temps des travaux cas
la dernière question qui je pose je
pense se poser à vous c'est les combien
ça coûte
évidemment je peux pas vous répondre
comme ça mais ça dépend du type de
médiation dans laquelle vous allez vous
diriger sachez toutefois je lui ai dit à
Sion coûte à peu près moitié moins cher
une procédure judiciaire qui n'est pas
négligeable sur le site des sauts de
médiation qui s'est affiché vous pouvez
consulter la totalité de nos tarifs en
toute transparence vous pouvez également
nous appeler c'est gratuit pour avoir
plus d'information par rapport au coût
indiqué sur le site évidemment il faudra
rajouter les frais d'avocat pour autant
la totalité restera toujours inférieur à
une procédure judiciaire
qui en cuisse et beaucoup plus longue
en résumé la médiation c'est un
processus qui rapide confidentiel moins
cher qu'une procédure
sécurisé dans son exécution et vous avez
la main de A à Z puisque c'est vous qui
décidez quand est-ce que vous rentrez
quand est-ce que vous arrêtez et si les
solutions en Vienne
Merci pour votre écoute je crois qu'on
va pouvoir passer aux questions
en effet nous allons pouvoir passer aux
questions n'hésitez pas utiliser le chat
pour poser toutes les questions qui est
en tout cas merci à tous les quatre pour
votre intervention
j'espère que le format un petit peu
atypique
n'hésitez pas à profiter de ce moment
que vous avez expert sur place
disponible pour répondre à toutes les
questions que vous poser sur la
médiation
j'en profite pour vous dire que pour les
besoins de l'exercice bien évidemment
nous avions des médiateurs de
l'association et que la médiation ne se
fait pas et donc elle est vraiment
confidentiel
remercier à nouveau Christelle
et Véronique
peut-on faire
médiation a plus que 2 personnes
première question alors qui peut
répondre à cette question
notamment alors
ce sont les médiations
avec le par exemple associés dans une
société
question ces moments en profiter alors
surtout derrière vos écrans la chez vous
alors on vous fait des compliments sur
l'intérêt de la soirée dans bravo
ouais et d'ailleurs pendant le vide nous
avons multiplié les médiations en visio
et ça marche assez bien
finalement maintenant la plupart des
personnes se sont habitués
[Musique]
on a besoin finalement de dire que même
et d'être assisté sur la révolution
voilà donc il y a un développement
c'est une technique qui existe depuis
très longtemps
mais comment ça peut être mieux connu
du public
et davantage utilisé également par les
avocats
les entreprises laisse-moi bien
peut-être les entreprises ont peut-être
moins recours à la médiation est-ce que
vous avez ce type de type de particules
sur quel type de conflit
[Musique]
c'est
un super outil la médiation c'est une
boîte à outils qui concerne la
communication donc c'est vrai que je
rebondis sur ce que dit Véronique ça
peut être utilisé complètement en avant
sur la gestion de projet c'est un super
petit sur la gestion de projet
poser une question sur le temps moyen la
durée d'une médiation
c'est-à-dire que le code de procédure
civile et 3 mois
et 3 mois
3 mois
on a beaucoup plus de temps mais
ça va beaucoup plus vite
parce que
en vrai
et pour une solution donc ça peut aller
très vite
que nous faisons tous les quatre
précisément aux informations que nous
donnons
en réunion de 2h alors que le problème
de ta part être comme insoluble et bien
bouche sur une solution alors pas
directement aller sur tes deux heures
mais les avocats continue à parler entre
eux et nous sommes informés
effectivement dans les délais qu' il y a
eu un accord donc c'est un outil qui va
très très vite dès lors que les parties
l'ensemble des parties sont volontaire
pour participer en
tant que chef d'entreprise
aussi du temps pour trouver la solution
voilà alors il y a des questions
nouvelles qui se pose donc on a vu que
la pas le cas pratique ce soir c'est un
litige commercial est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir des médiations dans le relationnel
illustration de la médiation de gestion
de projet est véritablement
de la notion de médiation relationnel
c'est-à-dire que véritablement
sur la question
sur les entreprises
[Musique]
une relation de couple
oui
vraiment sa place
litige entre les consommateurs et les
service clientèle d'entreprises sont
parfois exclu des conventions de
médiation parce que c'était prévu par
les textes il faut vous référer au code
de la consommation et la médiation de la
consommation et encadrer au sein du Code
de la Consommation ce qui veut dire que
vous vous
devez avoir un médiateur de la
consommation et donc vos clients
satisfaits s'en réfère à ce médiateur
alors nous n'avons pas je suis par
ailleurs médiateur de la consommation
d'une entité médiation de la
consommation nous n'avons pas le même
c'est-à-dire que nous écoutons certes
les deux parties en présence donc un
consommateur un professionnel mais c'est
nous qui trouverons une solution c'est
nous qui apporte une solution donc il
est parti on l'a dit que les gars ont la
liberté d'accepter ou de refuser
d'ailleurs et tout comme la médiation
c'est un processus volontaire donc
effectivement les professionnels ont
l'obligation de mettre en œuvre une
médiation de la consommation gratuite
pour le consommateur mais vous n'avez
pas l'obligation d'entrée en médiation
parce que par exemple pour certains
professionnels
la problématique donner le différend
n'est pas dans le respecte pas les
spécificités légale donc voilà pourquoi
c'est différent et vous avez donc par
ailleurs vous savez des médiateurs
institutionnels le médiateur de
l'énergie et vous avez aussi certains
secteurs vous avez par exemple le
médiateur de l'assurance le médiateur de
la Fédération Française
de la mutualité qui ont leur propre
mécanisme et sinon lorsque vous avez
pour les mutuelles et bien elle peut
contacter de médiation voilà pourquoi
c'est parce que nous sommes là score du
Code de la Consommation
la profession d'avocat
oui alors nous en avons un mais
nous sommes pas obligés de le prendre
c'est le consommateur
exactement
question de profil d'avocat est-il la
bonne attitude pour être partial
c'est
une posture on a pas de partir on va pas
prendre parti pour lui par l'autre donc
je pense que c'est ça
[Musique]
la des objets sociaux c'est
effectivement plusieurs médias plusieurs
avocats qui se sont intéressées en
discipline si je puis dire en notre
profession à la profession de médiation
[Musique]
l'habitude comme nous avons laissé
l'humour fait très rapidement un certain
nombre de paramètres mais pour le reste
un médiateur
pour
un avocat
et moi je voudrais compléter ce que je
viens de dire c'est que lorsque nous
sommes former lorsque nous nous formons
et nous sommes tous ici former donc
formation à la médiation à la
négociation
c'est-à-dire que lorsque nous arrivons
mais
surtout pas être
donc on prend
notre avocat
juste un dernier petit. Rappelez-vous le
médiateur n'a pas le droit de proposer
des solutions donc
il n'a pas le droit de
travail de l'avocat
une petite question
il essaie de vérifier s'il a bien
compris
venez venez les émotions voilà on crève
l'abcès
tout à l'heure on parlait de
bienveillance alors le mot est très
tendance il est
parti
subornation de domination de l'une des
parties par l'autre
alors il est
18h55 donc on si on a tenu les Delhaize
qui est quand même exceptionnel pour un
webinaire
présentation merci à la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat qui nous a
accueilli ce soir
[Musique]
mais
Valérie
[Musique]
Jean Charle Sandrine Sandrine
il est
vraiment un grand merci à toute l'équipe